[Musique]
bonjour à tous je me présente je
m'appelle henry je suis actuellement
nouveau bâtiment qui vient sortir de
terre et qui s'appelle les étincelles du
palais de la découverte
et oui comme comme saviez peut-être ou
pas parce que c'est un monument vraiment
de l'histoire de ba de la vulgarisation
scientifique à paris et en france en
général mais vraiment à paris c'est un
bâtiment qui existe depuis 1937 qui a
été fondée par jean perrin un grand
physicien quelques prix nobel d'ailleurs
et homme politique aussi donc qui a
fondé le palais de la découverte est
aussi une petite chose qu'on appelle le
cnrs le centre national de recherche
scientifique
rien que ça et donc ce palais de la
découverte il s'avère qu'il est en ce
moment en rénovation et donc c'est
justement l'objet de ce nouveau bâtiment
les et anciennes du palais de la
découverte qui sont là pour faire le
lien d'ici là réouverture du palais dans
les années 2000 24-25 a priori si je ne
m'abuse donc où on pousse à nous je vous
le demande
nous sommes au jardin caroline aigle qui
est située pas loin du parc andré
citroën dans le 15e arrondissement de
paris et je vous propose de découvrir ce
bâtiment
à l'occasion de son ouverture
aujourd'hui même 9 juin 2021 et donc
pour ça vous propose une petite
déambulation à l'intérieur de cet
endroit est aussi partir à la rencontre
de ces autres donc pour commencer
j'accueille bruno ma carte c'est le
président d'universcience universcience
qui est l'entité qui regroupe d'une part
la cité des sciences et de l'industrie
et d'autres parlent pas la découverte
donc bonjour monsieur le président
bonjour je suis ravi de votre présence
merci de nous en aurait donc tout
d'abord j'avais une petite histoire vous
poser pourquoi avoir créé ce centre de
sciences écoutez le palais de la
découverte est en travaux il était en
travaux pour plusieurs années et nous
voulions continuer à pouvoir accueillir
notre public pendant pendant ce temps là
et nous avons donc cherché un lieu dans
paris et nous sommes arrivés ici dans le
15ème arrondissement
dans ce jardin magnifique d'accord et
alors pourquoi ce choix de nous les
étincelles du palais de la découverte
3les et conseille alors les étincelles
ça évoque la science à évoque les
phénomènes sûr
fixa évoque les démonstrations
scientifiques c'est ce que nous faisons
c'est ce que nous proposons au public
ici c'est ce que nous proposons au
public évidemment depuis que nous
existons et est-ce qu'on retrouvera
après les travaux alors par ailleurs les
étincelles c'est ce qu'on a envie de
voir dans les yeux de nos visiteurs
quand ils nous rendent visite très blanc
c'est un peu audacieux d'avoir appelé ça
les essentiels pour un bâtiment
entièrement en bois je vais passer là
dessus donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter ce lieu justement qui
al'allure particulièrement étonnant tour
marx et pitau colorées qu'on aperçoit de
loin quand on se promène le mans
quartier alors c'est un bâtiment tout en
bois ça bâtiment écologiquement
responsable on n'a pas coulée de béton
c'est une façon de construire qui et
j'allais dire celle qui devrait être la
plus générale aujourd'hui on arrive dans
ce lieu magnifique et on pourra en
repartir en le laissant dans l'état dans
lequel on l'a trouvée c'est important et
puis par ailleurs on a poussé la
démarche jusqu'à réutiliser à
l'intérieur vous allez le découvrir dans
quelques instants
jusqu à réutiliser tout un tas de
matériaux qui était au palais de la
découverte et qu'on à réemployer ici
vous verrez lyonnais y en a de toutes
sortes
c'est une façon de dire aussi qu'on
s'appuie sur ce qu'on est
pour inventer ce qu'on va être c'est un
lien avec le passé mais c'est en même
temps une formidable projection dans le
futur on a voulu cette architecture
joyeuse pour signifier que c'était la
maison de tous
tout le monde est le bienvenu pour venir
assister à anost démonstration dans nos
salles d'ateliers dans notre planétarium
pour y rencontrer la science la
recherche présentée par des femmes et
des hommes dont c'est le métier qu'on
appelle des médiatrices et des
médiateurs et qui n'ont qu'une hâte
c'est d'accueillir tout le monde ici
parce que ça fait quand même un moment
que les musées n'ont pas pu totalement
remplir leur mission qui est
d'accueillir leur public dans leurs murs
d'accord donc l'idée c'est de se
réinventer sans oublier c'est d'avoir un
moment privilégié avec les publicains
entre deux puisque pendant les travaux
évidemment nous construisons nous
inventons ce que sera le palais à la
roue
arthur dans notre bâtiment historique
qui se fait totalement restaurée c'est
aussi un endroit dans lequel on va
expérimenter un certain nombre de choses
puisque le public est toujours très
disponible pour répondre à nos
sollicitations et est donc encore une
fois il est le bienvenu ici à tout âge
on vient en famille ont bien selon vient
en classe en tout cas il faut réserver à
l'avancé pour que évidemment chacun
puisse trouver l'activité qui lui plaît
très bien donc c'est un lieu pour tout
âge effectivement en famille les
scolaires aussi qui vont venir ici alors
les scolaires sont vous le savez les
bienvenus dans notre maison
on aura entre guillemets réservés les
jours de la semaine
et puis les familles les public
individuel comme on les appelle pour
revenir le mercredi après midi le samedi
et le dimanche comme ça chacun a sa
plage horaire et tout le monde peut tout
le monde peut venir et tout le monde
peut venir à paris mais aussi je suis
venu aux activités à distance puisque le
palais pendant les travaux fait d'autres
choses
il travaille avec des collègues en
région vers une exposition à bordeaux et
puis aussi présents présent sur la toile
avec une série de toute une série de
propositions nouvelles
préparé par les équipes et et qui vont
se déployer progressivement au cours des
mois qui viennent
d'accord et vos équipes font ça très
bien bref je vous remercie
je leur dirai dans votre part voilà eh
bien merci beaucoup vous nos macarons
merci à vous merci à vous j'ai hâte de
découvrir ce lieu j'espère que vous
aussi
j'accueille à présent l'architecte de ce
lieu loïc julienne architectes des
étincelles du palais de la découverte à
l'atelier construire alors bonjour loïc
julienne
merci d'être ici est-ce que vous pouvez
nous parler de la conception de ce lieu
quand même très original alors c'est est
heureuse d'annoncer un projet qui se
voulait quand même un écho de remballer
leur part et un bâtiment extraordinaire
qui a marqué son époque ont tenu à
marquer le paysage que paris de très
grande dimension avec les verrières a
été retrouvé un petit peu de cette
grandeur du grand palais dans ce petit
coin du 15ème arrondissement
alors c'était assez compliqué parce
qu'on avait un terrain contre un on est
coincé entre un contre un jardin un
cimetière dans un endroit un peu comme
ça cachés et donc le programme était
complexe aussi bien il devrait d'abord
respecter l'objectif du développement
durable et aussi répondre à sa faconde
éléments de programme et donc on a
décidé de construire en fait six modules
tous identiques de la même hauteur de la
dbm dimensions et ses six modules
correspondant aux différentes fonctions
du palais de la découverte et donc ils
sont montés assez haut pour exister dans
le paysage parisien et et on les a
coloré pour en faire un lieu un peu
vivent un peu gay pour que les enfants
s'y reconnaissent aussi un petit peu
très bien et alors est ce que vous
auriez une anecdote à nous raconter sur
la construction de ce bâtiment
alors il ya plein d'anecdotes d'abord il
a été il a été entièrement donc
préfabriqués en atelier plus monté sur
place pour ne pas gêner le quartier pour
faire un montage très rapide et il a été
quand vous voyez surélevé par rapport au
niveau du sol
puisqu'on est en fait dans un terrain
qui est inondable au sens où les crues
centennales de la scène tous les ans à
peu près la scène peut déborder de 110
et donc venir du coup je peux glisser
sous le bâtiment qui ne sera pas
atteinte à montée des eaux
voilà on espère quand même quand ils
viennent on n'ira pas droit - vous êtes
prêts pour aucun point très bien merci
beaucoup de julienne pour ses
explications
alors à présent je vous invite à aller à
l'intérieur de ce bâtiment on va le
découvrir ensemble on va pouvoir aller
voir tout ça et surtout ce qui se passe
à l'intérieur
et ça m'est avis que vous serez pas déçu
moi même je n'ai découvert que ce matin
je vous propose d'y aller allez suivez
moi nous sommes maintenant à l'intérieur
de ces et anciennes du palais de la
découverte
et oui nous y sommes et alors nous
allons découvrir bientôt
la chef des médiateurs du palais qui est
donc emmanuel lambert
allez c'est parti on y va tout doucement
et de profil aient mené lauber bonjour
tu es chef de département des immunités
scientifique tués dans une pièce avec
beaucoup d'échos mais nous avons des
bons microbes aura pas de problème donc
on a vu qu'il existait différents
chapiteaux de couleur brune au mas carte
vous expliquer tout ça comment ils sont
habités ces différents chapiteaux
comment ça va fonctionner alors l'idée
c'est vraiment ici de conserver la même
offre que nous avions dans le 8e
arrondissement donc c'est à dire que
nous avions cette discipline nous les
conservons mais par une raison de faute
de place on a été obligé d'associer de
faire des duos on va dire d'obligations
donc vous allez avoir dans la première
salle les disciplines chimie et
géosciences dans la deuxième physique
informatique et sciences numériques dans
la troisième les sciences de la vie et
les mathématiques et à la fin le
planétarium avec un beau ciel étoilé
le clou du spectacle très bien et donc
est ce qu'il ya des activités
incontournables à à ne pas contourner
alors on va effectivement retrouver les
grands classiques que nous avions déjà
eu dans le palais de la découverte c'est
à dire tout ce qui a trait aux vivants
les fourmis les grenouilles
on va retrouver les grands classiques
des sciences de la terre que sont les
dinosaures les volcans les séismes
on va avoir aussi ce côté un peu plus
moderne avec les robots l'intelligence
artificielle pouvoir aller à l'intérieur
de la matière avec par exemple réaction
toujours hors les molécules y ont
également aussi avec l'électrostatique
la physique est donc bien évidemment les
mathématiques qui sont la science de
tous parfaits et alors est ce qu'il ya
des nouveautés à côté de ça alors
effectivement en parallèle vous allez de
savoir retrouver oui ça tombe bien donc
leader c'est qu'effectivement en
comparaison de ses grands classiques qui
sont quand même réadapté pour ce lieu on
va retrouver ce qu'on appelle les
activités du laboratoire de la médiation
l'idée c'est vraiment d'essayer de
concevoir avec le public des nouveaux
formats médiation en faisant appel
justement l expertise de ses publics ça
peut être une expertise professionnelle
ça peut être une expertise on va dire
individuelle et donc tout ça on va
commencer à le développer à partir de la
rentrée prochaine
d'accord très bien
et petits détails qui n'étaient pas
prévues est ce que tu pourrais définir
le métier de médiateur parce que
peut-être que tout le monde sait pas ce
que c'est le métier le médiateur je
dirais puisque comme je lé pratiqué
pendant 20 ans personnellement que c'est
la personne qui va faire le lien entre
le monde de la recherche et le grand
public c'est à dire utiliser tous les
moyens à notre disposition pour
expliquer ce qu'est la science et c'est
vrai qu'ici on a aussi cette approche un
peu ludique qui est notamment révélé par
ces fameux code de couleurs d'accord et
alors si j'ai envie de venir ici comment
je fais alors réserver sa place oui pour
venir systématiquement il faut passer
par le site internet du palais des
découvertes donc ici ce sont les
étincelles du palais de la découverte le
site internet
réservation obligatoire et profitez donc
parce que justement on noue avec une
semaine de gratuité pour l'ensemble de
nos publics qu'ils soient scolaires ou
individuelles annoncé très bien merci
beaucoup et modèle eh ben je t'en prie
bonne visite merci je continue donc
cette déambulation avec baptiste bureau
que je découvre ici
donc tu es designers à chanter c'est toi
qui es tu occupes de la mise en scène de
la scénographie des expositions à
l'université des sciences
voilà la cité des sciences et
anciennement palais de la découverte
voilà et donc c'est toi qui était chargé
de d'habiter ces différents chacun voilà
de réaliser tous les tous les meubles en
tout les agencement intérieur dudit
palais éphémère de thym sel
alors donc tu as tout réaliser on est
parti avec les moyens du bord donc une
vache peut-être exemple sur eux sur
cette banque d'accueil où là on retrouve
des revues découverte qui avaient été
stockées par par les médiateurs
notamment et qui partent à la mène et
donc on les a on les a sauvés de de la
poubelle au même titre que au même titre
que ce plateau de qui est qui qui
provient de la banque d'accueil du
palais découvertes qu'on a qu'on a
recoupé qu'on a rassemblé on retrouve
des panneaux en bois de la salle
informatique
on retrouve là l'accueil du dinosaure du
balcon terre et vie ici c'est une c'est
une vitrine de mathématiques et là ce
sont des éléments de du balcon terry
également que qu'on utilise est là pour
la pour la pour la banque d'accueil mais
qu'on va retrouver le plus tard dans
d'autres salles il faut savoir qu'il ya
presque on estimé à
17 tonnes le poids des matériaux qu'on a
qu'on a qu'on a sauvés de la benne est
qu on a réutilisé pour les aménagements
qu'on va découvrir
d'accord c'est parfait écoute merci
beaucoup je te propose de m'accompagner
pour aller visiter un peu ses différents
modules nous expliquer un peu ce qui est
nouveau et ce qui ne l'est pas et ce qui
ne l'est pas
[Musique]
à la découverte du premier module qui
parle chimie et de géosciences auquel
belle science allons-y suis moi alors
baptiste raconte-nous alors voila voila
comme vous le voyez nous sommes dans la
salle qui traite de la chimie hélas que
tu touches c'est le tableau de
mendeleïev est donc là tu es en train de
caresser un panneau de bois qui vient de
l'exposition lumière
à côté de ça on a des fragments de
l'école des rares ici c'était des
panneaux de la salle chimie est comme ça
que l'on retrouve une dizaine
d'expositions de la découverte et dont
on a récupéré les panneaux de bois et on
les a gravé pour pour constituer des
lieux c'est pas des tirages il ya un
petit brouillard
voilà et là par exemple on retrouve
également le parquet qui était qui
étaient présents donc c'est un parquet
en chêne massif qui était qui avait été
posée en 1937 et donc été au courant
alors affaire un imam et qui ont
reconstitué ici pour fabriquer les
estrades qu'on retrouve donc au chimique
on retrouve en physique et en biologie
et mathématiques et ses chats sont quand
même assez oui alors comme comme tous
les autres matériaux donc tous les
matins où vous l'avez compris son sons
proviennent du recyclage celles ci elles
ne proviennent pas en revanche
directement du pis la découverte elles
proviennent de différentes écoles pour
les assises et on les a on les a
bricolées pour que pour les adapter à
des sièges de bureau pour pouvoir avoir
des pistons pourquoi régler les auteurs
pour certaines certaines d'entre elles
et donc comme tu le vois elle se tourne
pour pouvoir donc soit consultée côté
chimie soit le côté geoscience que voici
alors j'ai aussi on retrouve quasiment
l'intégration qui étaient présentes au
palais de la découverte
on a aussi permis coquetterie on a
rajouté les cartels de bright qui était
présent sur le sur le balcon terre et
vie pour constituer cette crédence la
géologie en braille la géologie en
braille exactement
et alors je vais juste un petit un petit
focus sur les porte-manteaux donc tout à
l'heure j'ai parlé de la frise
de la frise du balcon terre et vie et
donc on a récupéré les pleins comme ça
en aluminium conte à cintrer pour
constituer tous les porte manteaux de
toutes les salles dont vous ne verrez il
y aura régulièrement dans chacune des
salles que c'est beau il peut accrocher
ses manteaux sur sur des millions
d'années sur des millions d'acheteurs
olala qu'est ce que c'est vous merci
bâtisse pour s'offrir un moment j'ai
hâte de te retrouver à bientôt
je vous propose maintenant à présent
d'aller côté chimie pour aller voir
notre amie sarah sarah bonjour tu es
chimie sa médiatrice gémissent
médiatrice si on est du côté chimie de
la salle de chimie géologie et donc je
vous propose un petit à petit avant goût
petit amuse bouche de ce qu'on fait on
exposait tu as dit on est dans la salle
de chimie et biochimie ce qui nous
intéresse c'est la matière on observe la
matière on essaie de comprendre de quoi
est constituée la matière donc manipuler
la matière on essaie de transformer la
matière tout ça en passant par des
expériences et donc c'est ce que je vous
propose une petite expérience une
version un peu raccourcie avec une
matière que vous connaissez peut-être
qu'ils s'appellent du peroxyde
d'hydrogène
alors là dit comme ça peroxyde
d'hydrogène on n'est pas sûr parce que
j'en ai fait moi pas chez moi si je vous
le dit autrement si je vous parle
d'oxygéner bien là dit oui ma salle de
bains mon armoire à pharmacie
alors il ya une petite différence entre
l'oxygène et que j'ai ici est celle
qu'on achète à la pharmacie moi je vais
utiliser de l'eau oxygénée concentre à
33% donc à peu près 10 fois plus
concentrée que l'oxygène et qu'on
utilise à la maison donc je vais prendre
quelques précautions un donc j'ai des
blues
je vais utiliser des gants pour protéger
mes mains hop
si j'arrive à les mettre dans le bon
sens évidemment c'est la partie la plus
technique de toute manipulation
et puis je vais aussi utiliser une paire
de lunettes pour protéger mes yeux et
avoir un style incomparable évident
toujours être cocasse quand évidemment
pas de pied là et donc un fort manipuler
donc je vais verser un petit peu d'eau
oxygénée
dans ce risque qui s'appelle une
éprouvette graduellement pour ceux qui
se rappellent leur tp de physique-chimie
et donc si je verse l'eau oxygénée
on constate que
pour le moment il se passe pas grand
chose déjà c'est un liquide transparent
attention c'est un liquide transparent
je vous dis ça s'appelle de l'oxygène
est donc bon on pourrait se dire c'est
l'eau attention est vraiment pas de
l'eau tout court c'est de l'eau oxygénée
et ça va lui donner les propriétés
particulières alors donc je me dis on
essaie de transformer la matière là à
l'évidence il ne se passe pas grand
chose
peut-être que ça se transforme mais
c'est pas une transformation qui est
visible donc moi je vous propose
d'essayer de faire en sorte qu'on ait
une transformation visible et pour ça on
va rajouter une poudre qui s'appelle de
iodure de potassium salut odeur de
potassium en général on n'a pas à la
maison ça sert pas vraiment dans la vie
de tous les jours mais ça va nous
permettre de déclencher
notre réaction vient visiter alors je
pourrai le faire comme ça directement
mais c'est quand même ouverture des
étincelles du palais de la découverte
oui mais c'est de rendre c'est un petit
peu plus visuel un petit peu plus
grandioses et pour ça je vais rajouter
deux chevaux alors tout d'abord j'ai
rajouté du colorant alors là pas de
secret le colorant sa sert a coloré dans
la presse des choses aujourd'hui
alors je m la dose sans ça ça va être
très foncé pour le début de l'expérience
ces couacs en colorant alors c'est du
colorant alimentaire verts qui a l'air
très foncé pour le moment il fait un peu
marre ont pour le moment effectivement
c'est pas très appétissant deuxième
interdit alors là du coup ça va plus du
tout être absent je vais rajouter du
liquide vaisselle du savon liquide up
est donc là pour le monde sait toujours
pas grand chose et donc tout simplement
c'est que notre collants et notre
liquide vaisselle
ils réagissent pas spécialement avec
l'oxygène et se passe pas grand chose je
pourrais très bien m'en passer ce qui
est intéressant ce qui est important
c'est notre poudre notre iodure de
potassium
alors pour rajouter iodure de potassium
tuvalu me placer sous la hotte aspirante
c'est une précaution supplémentaire et
que c'est plus pratique pour le ménage
c'est parfait donc je me place sous la
hotte
je prends une bonne spatule dur dur de
potassium
en est donc là pour le coup il se passe
quelque chose
on observe çà fait rapidement et le
moose tu es donc volontiers tu nous lis
que ça chauffe alors pourtant tu n'as
pas mis les mains dedans
ce qui donne l'impression que ça chauffe
c'est qu'effectivement on voit une
espèce de brouillard une buée qui se
dépose sur les parois donc effectivement
ça chauffe
donc si on regarde bien on a deux
phénomènes on a une mousse qui se
forment et un brouillard annuel est donc
en fait à partir de ces observations les
bains ont peu à peu près comprendre ce
qui s'est passé 1
alors là je vous faire la version un
petit peu raccourcie mais en gros une
mousse c'est du gaz emprisonné dans
quelque chose en l'occurrence du savon
et ce gaz il n'était pas là au départ
donc ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'on a
formé un gaz dans notre cas c'est de
l'oxygène du dioxygène je devrais dire
que l'oxygène ça marche aussi celle de
nombreux avantages
cet occident il s'est formé à partir
d'eau oxygénée
alors si on a de l'eau oxygénée et qu on
en extrait l'oxygène il nous reste de
l'obl on voit là et comme l'amanite
chauffe et basses et hautes de
brouillard cette vapeur qui ressemble
beaucoup à ce qui se passe quand en fait
je fais une casserole
voilà donc en gros c'est le type de
m'hamid qu'on fait dans cette salle on
en fait plein d'autres à l'idée c'est de
voir que la chimie elle est partout
autour de nous dans la vie de tous les
jours et donc par ce système de manip
observations déduction mais bon on doit
aborder des sujets aussi variés que
l'énergie les plastiques la
criminalistique les odeurs les couleurs
bref tout un exposé en tout cas toute
l'équipe de chimie est impatiente de
vous accueillir
on espère vous se voir nombreuses ombres
en chimie bah écoute on a de revenir
vous de venir pour les bons pour
apprendre et c'est évidemment la mère
partie ce jour avoir un chimiste ou les
chinois le savent je me tourne à présent
vers le coin géosciences qui comme son
nom l'indiqué est un point qui parle de
cailloux et donc forcément ça
m'intéresse à la route
nous allons à la découverte olivier
coulon qui est donc médiateur en
cailloux olivier raconte nous et bien
tu as déjà trouver tout de suite les
exemplaires qu'ils nous n'a rapatrié une
bonne quantité de nos échantillons
presque tout ce qu'ils vont nous
permettre de traiter l'essentiel de nous
exposer alors par exemple si on se
tourne sur le côté eh ben on peut voir
que la paléontologie va être à l'honneur
nous avons deux types d'exposer donc là
nous avons l'évolution de l'espèce
humaine avec des tas de petits
personnages radi nous avons rencontré le
public bientôt
et sinon l'exposé consacré aux
dinosaures avec à nouveau quelques
exemplaires sont des reproductions de
fossiles et quand les conditions
sanitaires le permettront les gens
pourront à peut regarder ça de très près
dès que ce sera possible et caresser les
cailloux comme tu avais commencé donc là
j'ai mis quelques roches mais en fait
nous en avons encore énormément dans les
placards pour divers exposés nous aurons
aussi des météorites
alors là je ne les ai pas à mener mais
nous avons des exposés consacré aux
météorites et à une promenade géologique
sur mars
ah ouais carrément alors la moindre
roche mais quand même il peut y avoir
des surprises sinon les roches et bien
il ya un exposé qui leur est totalement
dédié ce que disent les pierres et là
c'est l'occasion de partir un peu
c'est très ouvert qu'on discute qu'est
ce que me racontait l'auroch tel
fossiles et si nous nous avons les
grands classiques consacré à l'évolution
du climat aux climats du passé avec le
changement climatique pas fortement
d'actualité et tout ce qui est
géodynamique tectonique des plaques
formation des montagnes volcanisme et
séisme et justement puisque je te parle
des séismes
j'ai aussi une petite manip alors à elle
aura besoin sans doute d'un petit
rafraîchissement
mais déjà elle me permet de montrer aux
essayer de provoquer entre manquèrent
pas ici dans les lieux ce serait bien
triste comme un mets de simuler ça alors
là on a des petits blocs de pierre il
faut imaginer que ça représente à peu
près 10 km de croûte terrestre et on va
lancer un petit moteur qui exercent une
tension qui va exercer en fait des
contraintes sur ces blocs de roche qui
sont prêts fracturé en ce qu'on appelle
une faille et on voit au début qu'il ne
se passe rien regardez
impressionnant ça c'est incroyable voilà
un exposé où il ne se passe strictement
rien basse il faut être patient mais ben
voilà on a raté mais d'un coup ça a
lâché qui on voit surtout alors là c'est
voilà ça fonctionne par à coups alors là
sur la fin bon ça avançait quand même
très régulièrement comme ça mais
normalement ce qu'on l'a vu mais j'étais
en train de parler pendant parce que
c'est ça qui est génial avec les
commentaires c'est qu'on peut pas les
pouvoirs mais pas si génial que ça mais
disons que ça permet de comprendre les
forces accumulés à la roche les 10 puis
d'un coup ça lâche et ce qu'on a vu un
moment c'est que ça serve à ça bouge et
ça libérer l'énergie puis ça sert coincé
qu'après ça rebouge est alors vers la
fin ça nous ont un peu régulièrement
mais l'idée c'est vraiment le principe
du cycle sismique
tant qu'il y aura des contraintes
appliquées il ya blocage libération
d'énergie ça bouffe blocage libération
d'énergie ça vous à chaque libération
d'énergie sa fin si tu vois là et on le
croisait avec les petits ressorts pas
très joli ballet voir que quand même un
peu amplifié pelouse en plus c'est
magnifique
donc ça bon c'est un petit moyen
d'aborder sa acquis pour conclure si on
veut replacer par exemple tous ces
séismes sur les grandes structures
géologiques
nous avons notre magnifique globe en
relief alors surtout ce qui est génial
dans ce club c'est qu'on a les reliefs
océanique donc là par exemple j'ai pris
exprès le pacifique puisque comme ça on
voit cette origine volcanique des fonds
océaniques
on repère des grandes structures où
justement pourrait se produire des
séismes
là par exemple il ya la fosse des
mariannes un endroit de plus profonde
globe de chlore n'imagine quand même
quelques grandes fractures
comme on l'a vu à ces femmes place qui
plonge ce qu'on appelle la subduction
est donc ce globe terrestre dans poil
toucher à nouveau quand les conditions
sanitaires le permettront et notamment
on utilise assez souvent pour les
publics déficients visuels
c'est très pratique pour repérer
certaines zones importantes
voilà donc nous espérons vous voir
bientôt nombreuses et nombreux pour
participer à nos voyages dans l'espace
et dans le temps et pour venir caresser
d'australie voilà par exemple
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]
nous voici dans le coin physique
informatique et sciences de du numérique
oui je est à nos côtés
voici pour de bonjour jean claud rapide
de te revoir
alors nous emmène à la découverte
waouh et là aussi tout est aussi tout
est d'époque jusqu'à jacques d'ailleurs
qui est 100% henry emploi par ravis ils
écoutent pas de même façon que tout à
l'heure je n'y aura peut-être des
rythmes et donc tous les mobiliers que
ce soit là parce que ce soit le cas car
que ce soit le sol tout et tout est
récupéré et réalisé à partir des
matériaux pour trouver essentiellement
là dans la salle d'exposition lumière
donc comme sa définition peuvent
retrouver leur heure leur univers
ils sont dans leur habitat naturel que
ce soit rapide d'accords de l'autre côté
qui informatique dont conditionner sa
d'exposer avec des médiations du parc de
l'atelier livré fin 2011 et à l'atelier
enfants mais bon c'est vraiment en ce
moment là
[Musique]
et les femmes des restes ça marche mais
merci bonjour on va parler d'eux dit
physique va pas détricoter très très
large du terme puisque on pas aussi bien
parler de tout ce qui est changement
d'état carmaux dynamique les très basses
températures
là on va descendre à moins 196 degrés on
va parler de fluide on va parler de gaz
de liquide du vide et on va parler de ce
qui fait qu'un avion vole ou qu'un
bateau flotte
on va également parlé des ondes des
vibrations mais aussi de la lumière
on va parler du magnétisme de
l'électromagnétisme et puis on va sur
par les ondes acoustiques du son du son
musical notamment le fameux fond musical
et bas comme on est au palais de la
découverte
on pouvait difficilement se passer de
parler b et oui alors ne soit pas dans
la grande salle électrostatique mais oui
vous aurez les cheveux qui se dressent
en dedans nouveaux remous je vais
prendre quelques instants faut vraiment
qu'on règle ce problème
je suis donc le 24 pour monter une
espérance que je trouve particulièrement
jolie quand on parle vibrations et
d'onde
là j'ai une plaque de métal à l'aide de
cette arche et je vais la faire vibrer
les vibrations vont se promener se
propager dans dans la plaque sous forme
d'onde et vont se mélanger les unes aux
autres et quand une vibration une onde
rencontre d'autres vibrations il peut se
passer
deux choses principalement ou alors
bowes qui rencontre une bosse quand
elles se croisent double bosse ou un
creux qui rencontre un creux double
creux ça c'est la première la première
possibilité
deuxième possibilité c'est une bosse
rencontre un creux ils vont s'annuler
c'est exactement ce qui va se passer
dans cette plaque ya des endroits où les
boisons s'additionner aux bosses ça va
monter très haut en vibrant il ya des
endroits où les bosses il est creux vont
s'annuler villeroy c'est comme si ça me
brûle si cela ne vire pas du tout cela
un peu jolie ce n'était pas déjà assez
je dépose sur la tête du sable
ce sable va être injecté les endroits où
ça vibre beaucoup pour tomber pour aller
se réfugier loxam vibre pas donc ce
sable va décider ce qu'on appelle les
figures de khl admis et voilà le sale
des signes fait fuir de camille alors
comme pour chaque mot chaque plaque
chaque façon de vivre et correspond à
une note est bon en quelque sorte voir
des notes de musique
le prendre juste encore quelques
instants hop là pour montrer une autre
manière l attaque a dit brees mais pour
cela souvenez-vous les endroits où jean
houle attaque ne vibre pas c'est là où
le sabre va s'accumuler et ben je vais
imposer les endroits où l'impact et
vieux repas je pose un doigt ici à
douala et je sais déjà que l'un est là
la plaque mais vire au drame
attention le sont beaucoup plus aiguë
c'est pas très agréable mais c'est joli
d'accord nous voilà c'est ça qu'on a pu
dire de clavier je voulais vraiment
montrer ça parce que ça tout à fait
magnifique
alors on va maintenant pouvoir enfin
expliquer le pourquoi du comment de ce
et planches de bois
ces planches de bois recouvre ce qui
sera dans quelques temps pas trop
longtemps dans quelques temps qui
recouvre as qui va qu un élément sur
lequel on pourra faire limite t on aura
vraiment un surf électromagnétique qui
va limiter au dessus des rails et tout
le monde pourra pouvoir pour l'essayer
oui comme dans retour vers le futur est
faible tu peux avoir déjà essayé je peux
vous dire que ça vaut le détour
très bien merci beaucoup voilà et ben
merci beaucoup à tous bienvenue quoi
vous êtes bien bien évident les
bienvenus dans l'espace physique que
vous soyez fan de physique ou que vous
ne soyez pas c'est également très
important quelques secondes parce qu
elle tient beaucoup à coeur parce que
ben c'est la guitare sur laquelle albert
einstein à composer l'équipe bis awards
incroyable je pense que c'est ma je vais
méditer ces bateaux alors maintenant je
me dirige vers l'autre côté de la salle
qui est le coin informatique et sciences
du numérique et je vais retrouver
emilien et me lire bonjour tu es donc
médiator ici de quoi tu nous parler tous
trompés celle là est axée un peu tous
les jours mais on sait pas forcément ce
qui se passe derrière et clairement il
ya énormément de choses qui sont super
intéressant à découvrir
et malgré l'âge de ceux de ce domaine
scientifique qui est clairement très
très jeune en gros l'informatique
moderne on va dire c'est à peu près les
années 50 par rapport aux taux science
on est quand même très jeune et bien il
ya des choses absolument fascinante à
découvrir dans ce domaine là alors en
particulier je vais parler de robots on
vend on parle de robot dans les exposés
dont par exemple now show poche de
prenzlau donc c'est un petit robot il
est assez connu tu as peut-être déjà vu
sa tête
marie-pascale folie là où tu es là il
est un peu sourd de la fire là où tu es
là voilà il est aussi svelte que moi au
réveil
ah bah oui ça fait un petit moment que
ça a commencé désolé donc now donc c'est
ainsi un robot relativement récent en
fait il permet de faire énormément de
choses il y les programmes dont être de
manière assez facile et il nous
accompagne dans les exposés donc on peut
un peu un petit peut interagir avec lui
ce qui est assez sympa mais bon là où
c'est un sens et sans lien ultra récent
et du coup ça passait pas forcément
représentatif de toute l'informatique
un pardon milla soir au moulin ce robot
là c'est mon insu renommée spot c'est
électrique dogues avec très grave en
fait c'est une reproduction du tout
premier robot qui a été inventé et sa
date de 1912 et 1912 ses avants les
ordinateurs un concrètement on avait on
a dit on a eu des robots avant les
ordinateurs ce qui est assez surprenant
donc voilà donc c'est une reproduction
tout ce qui est tout ce qu'elle a dans
tous ces cas là dedans c'est que c'est
relativement récent par contre parce
qu'on a un petit peu modernisé mais ce
qu'ils avaient à l'époque notamment les
ordinateurs vendus électronique
concrètement si plus trouvable ça en
tête du coup la moderniser mais il
fonctionne toujours pareil donc je
t'invite à revenir si tu as envie de
voir un petit peu comment il fonctionne
cela je peux pas trop le faire rouler
ses impasses et aidez-le à l'eau
l'informatique c'est un domaine ultra
important parce que concrètement c'est
un domaine jeune et il faut forcément
qu'ils soient basés sur d'autres
d'autres choses et en l'occurrence les
maths et la physique c'est ultra
important dans cette histoire là est un
petit peu exploré ces aspects là c'est
c'est vraiment primordial pour bien
comprendre comment ça fonctionne et
découvrir un peu toutes les merveilles
qui est autour de ça avoir un objet que
j'aime que j'adore c'est celui là celui
là c'est un disque dur alors pour pour
information qui fait un giga 5 et c'est
à peu près la taille d'un film tu peux
plus que la taille d'un film donc là
dedans on peut stocker un film 12 kg
nous fallait si le travail est celui-là
est en gros ça on a commencé à utiliser
sa début des années soixante dix à peu
prés jusqu'aux années 80 et donc c'était
très répandu dans les entreprises
par contre un autre objet un peu plus
original c'est celui là
celui-là c'est un relais
électromécaniques et ça ce truc là c'est
ce qu'ont utilisé dans les premiers
ordinateurs pour arriver à faire du
calcul c'est quand même assez surprenant
concrètement parce que comment on peut
faire du calcul avec ça les sages
demande on a tout un exposé qui
l'expliqué super intéressant est
impressionnant donc voilà du coup c'est
on présente un petit peu tous ces
aspects là donc ça va aller de du coeur
de l'informatique c'est à dire ça va
être en gros comment fonctionne le
patron de la petite centrale de calcul
d'un téléphone jusqu'à des applications
très concrètes comme l'inde chance
artificielle comment on fait pour que le
téléphone quand on lui parle il puisse
se reconnaissent qu'on lui dise qui est
qu'ils puissent nous répondre ces choses
qui sont assez situations intéressantes
à découvrir et surtout assez
spectaculaire dans lequel 1,3
artificielle on a des choses vraiment
balèze quoi et on peut essayer de faire
des choses nous-mêmes exactement du coup
les ateliers donc qu'on que que tu as
montré tout à l'heure en gros les
ateliers ça permet aux gens de manipuler
un petit peu donc fait un petit peu de
robotique on habitue robot sympa tout
rigolo qu'on peut manipuler qu'on peut
programmer pour leur faire un peu ce
qu'on veut et en plus de ça on peut
faire aussi des quelques petits ateliers
de de codage pour faire des jeux vidéo
des choses comme ça qu'on programme
qu'on proposera plus tard superbe écoute
merci beaucoup et libyens merci à toi tu
vas bientôt vous invite à aller voir
tous ensemble on va découvrir le module
suivant
[Musique]
voici nous voici à présent dans le
module sciences de la vie et
mathématiques
allons-y bonjour fernando qu'y at-il de
vieux danse et tout et tout et tout est
vieux tout a commencé par parler de pi
parlons de 10 à celui ci voilà mes deux
pieds excellent qui ils ont repris des
décimales de pi donc qui était qui était
présente donc que tu peux voir là au
plafond et qui était présente depuis
l'origine du père éric ouverte dans la
salle la salle plie donc et il se trouve
que donc au moment de la vente des
décimales de pi à la vente aux enchères
il restait les traces de colle ddd si
mal sur le sur les panneaux en bois et
ça rentre plutôt plutôt bien et est
coupable le gros coup de bol vêtements
et l'autre gros coup de bol c'est que il
pour pouvoir le suspendre il fallait
appliquer un vernis fusion pour pour le
traité au feu et en appliquant ce vernis
ça fait ça pour racheter les chiffres
qui n'apparaissait que très faiblement
qu'au début et tout à coup on s'est
retrouvé avec eux ce résultat un beau
tour de magie et après comme comme pour
les autres salles mon jeu je peux le
redire mais tous les tous les matériaux
qui ont été utilisés du sol au plafond
proviennent de différentes expositions
et notamment pour elle et ses tables qui
sont réalisées à partir des panneaux de
la salle informatique
bonjour stéphanie nous tuer maîtrise en
biologie et en sciences de la vie
sciences de la vie donc là on attend que
moi et chez mes collègues aux unités
merci de nous accueillir non explosées
différents à vous proposer
et comme disait baptiste aura la chance
d'avoir des tables on va pouvoir se
rassure les gens ça fait déjà pas mal et
ils vont pouvoir bricoler manipuler
public va apprendre à utiliser un
microscope ou
voilà comment ça fonctionne et surtout
d'observer les choses des cellules à
base végétale suppléments de bagages
sortie de l'audition aller à quelques
bassins féminin et masculin qui vont
vous permettre de parvenir john key
d'organes vitaux de votre musique de
sexualité pour partir de 13 ans ont
réparé de cet organe qui est la leur en
ce moment c'est la collection automne
hiver
qu'est-ce que ça mais c'est éphémère les
pouvoirs pour venir vous voir
et justement ça c'est celui qu'on voit
un peu partout en ce moment c'est une
maquette un peu stylisé et on a la
chance d'avoir ici des maquettes qui
sont plus réalistes qui montre que pour
comme pour n'importe quel organe pas
l'effort paris en fonction des personnes
après je vous ai préparé un début de
manipulation ici où on va parler adn
alors normalement cette expérience
d'extraction de l'adn on l'a fait à
partir de salle il des visiteurs donc il
va falloir encore attendre un petit peu
avant qu'on puisse la faire à partir de
salive c'est pas trop le moment du coup
là je vous ai préparé un petit jus
d'oignons j'ai fait les premières étapes
il vous dit pas ce que j'ai fait comme
ça vous êtes encore une fois que j'ai de
venir nous voir je vous fais juste la
fin donc à partir de ce jus d'oignons je
rajoute à un dernier produit et croisant
les doigts
c'est un peu décevant
je ne sais pas si on voit bien mais un
peu oui oui ici là on voit apparaître
des filaments blancs qui sont
décidemment d'apn j'en avais préparé
avant là on voit beaucoup mieux si vous
venez après cette crise sanitaire on
pourra le faire à part
votre salive et vous pourrez repartir
avec votre adn dans un tube là aussi
automne hiver en pendentif
voilà c'est pourra servir à ce clown et
après commerce
oui on en reparlera c'est pas si facile
à bogota est ce qu'on peut parler de
cette personne qui voit la santé olivier
il a un peu raté c'est à manipuler m'a
dit donc là il se repose un peu
le pauvre la logique il faut croire
alors qui c'est pas un bonnet de bain
qu'il a sur la tête ça c'est notre poste
d'électrophysiologie donc on va pouvoir
soient enregistrés les ondes cérébrales
de nos cobayes
bon là ça marche pas très bien il est
pas hyper en forme mais voilà ça va nous
permettre de parler de sommeil donc si
vous êtes un gros dormeur venez nous
voir parce qu'on a du mal à faire dormir
le public dans nos salles qu'on est
tellement passionnante donc on aimerait
bien un jour que quelqu'un s'endorment
pour de vrai pour qu'on puisse montrer
en direct au public la différence au
niveau des ondes cérébrales entre les
phases d'éveil et de sommeil ça va
olivier oui et puis là si j'arrive à
vous montrer on a aussi des électrodes
qu'on peut mettre sur les poignets pour
cette fois-ci parler du coeur et
enregistrer un électrocardiogramme
envoie le laisser là ça ne va plus voilà
et sinon pour pour finir je voulais vous
parler de notre vache qui a beaucoup plu
à baptiste et de nos petites bactéries
et de cette poule que j'adore on peut
l'appeler pirika comme empirique à
pierrick assister si ça te plaît
quelqu'un écoute d'accord on a l'air
contente donc ça c'est pour parler c'est
très sérieux de vaccination de vaccin
donc surtout bon on va parler d'histoire
de vaccination pour vous expliquer un
peu comment on a mis au point les
premiers vaccins donc ils ont été faits
à partir de bestioles et puis bien sûr
comme c'est d'actualité on va parler
aussi de vaccins plus récents comme le
vaccin contre la colline pour vous
expliquer un peu comment fonctionne le
système immunitaire pourquoi c'est
parfois très loin de mettre au point un
vaccin et pourquoi t'es fois ça va très
très vite
alors dans cette salle on n'a pas que
des animaux en peluche on a aussi des
vrais animaux mais pour ça je laisse la
parole à pauline qui est bien plus doué
que moi sur le sujet à part fait alors
bonjour pauline bonjour la lentille
solide comme tu travaillais au lavoir du
vivant
qu'est ce que c'est donc que ceci alors
travaillé au laboratoire du vivant très
simple c'est concevoir des expériences
pour expliquer un phénomène biologique
donc tous les animaux qui forcément ont
été choisis pour les étincelles ont pas
été choisi par hasard ce que vous pouvez
voir sur toute la paillasse quand on
déroule vous verrez au fur et à mesure
on voit différents terrarium qui ont été
conçus exprès pour l'occasion pour
respecter le bien-être de l'animal
parce que à force de travailler avec eux
on est avec eux depuis déjà quelques
années donc on connaît bien leur cycle
de développement pour leur permettre de
se développer le mieux possible
on commence par les grenouilles aller
alors les grenouilles elles sont
utilisées dans un exposé qui parle de
démarche expérimentale avec le chargé
d'exposer vous apprendrez comment on
fait pour y arriver et quel cheminement
on doit suivre
ce sont des grenouilles rieuse donc
peut-être que pendant l'exposé si vous
avez un peu de chance vous les entendrez
chanter la question auquel vous allez
essayer de répondre c'est comment les
grenouilles perçoivent t-il leurs proies
voilà donc je vous laisserai découvrir
comment ça se passe pendant l'exposé
juste à côté on a un terrarium donc on a
l'impression qu'il est vide
pas du tout en fait c'est une toute
petite bête qu'on trouve sous la mousse
je passe si vous pouvez la voir il
fallait tout à fait ça grouille donc
c'est ce qu'on appelle des cloportes
alors pourquoi on a voulu présenter des
cloportes parce que parfois bad les plus
petites bêtes elles font les plus
grandes choses c'est un animal qui
impacte extrêmement positivement le
cycle de vie de nos sols donc on peut
presque dire que c'est un engrais
naturel alors c'est assez intéressant
aussi parce que l'on se demande souvent
dans quelle classe d'animaux ils sont
dans l'arbre du vivant
est-ce que c'est des insectes parce que
c'est tout autre chose vous l'apprendrez
du coup je vous laisserai découvrir ça
on exposer d'accord si je peux me
permettre d'être juste qu'est ce que
c'est que ce pied alors les gens se
demandent ce qu'est ce que c'est ce pied
en fait en exposer donc c'est un diorama
qui représente le cycle de vie du
moustique
donc on vous expliquera comment on vous
expliquera donc quel est le site du
moustique est en fait on essaye de faire
deviner que c'est un moustique pourquoi
mais le moustique pique l'humain ils ont
mis un pied pour essayer de représenter
le lien entre les deux mais on a mis le
pied aussi parce que comme c'est au sol
et une partie du cycle du moustique se
passe dans l'eau avec les oeufs que vous
pouvez
vinet au dessus et les larmes en dessous
c'était pour ça le quai d'accord
extrêmement réaliste en tout cas rien
bilan est donc voir son groupe n'ont
aucun soucis donc ici vous avez laissé
thuan donc ce sont des petits
coléoptères
ils seront liés dans un exposé pour
découvrir le monde animal avec les
phasmes que vous avez juste là en bout
de paillasse dans cet exposé tendre est
pas plaint de maux différents comme de
cycle de reproduction de métamorphose
complète incomplète on vous parlera
d'écologie aussi ou encore de mimétisme
alors pour vous spolier un peu il ya une
de ces des espèces qui est capable de se
reposer sans la présence d'un mâle et
pour finir car le meilleur alors je dis
le meilleur parce que depuis que je
travaille au laboratoire du vivant je
travaille beaucoup avec les fourmis donc
on m'appelle madame et plus sérieusement
on a voulu vous présentez une colonie de
fourmis
parce que les fourmis sont des insectes
sociaux donc c'est des animaux qui
s'organisent en colonies et où les
tâches sont extrêmement bien répartis
c'est pour ça aussi que les chercheurs
les étudie depuis si longtemps pour leur
comportement ils ont elles ont des
moyens de communication qui sont très
précis on a choisi celle là aussi parce
qu'il ya quelques petites particularités
assez drôle ce sont des fourmis qui sont
capables de vivre sans rennes ce qui est
assez inédit pour une fourmilière et
c'est une fourmi dans le petit land art
est gratos salt à tort alors on vous
demandera pas de le retenir
par contre si vous tendez l'oreille salt
à tort effectivement ce sont des fourmis
sauteuses dos parce qu'elles ont des
mandibules en forme de harpon voilà pour
la biologie animale ce sera tous
j'espère vous avoir donné envie
d'assister aux exposés de biologie
animale
je vous souhaite une bonne journée il ya
bientôt cool merci beaucoup pauline avec
15,2 prochaine donc j'enchaîne avec
robin jamais une fois tu es mateu alors
je suis désolé
un objectif d'aider les gens que les
maths c'est sympa je suis payé pour
mais cela dit je le fais des fourneaux
et donc voilà dans cette salle là alors
les tables nous aussi on voulait avoir
des étapes l'une des choses qui nous est
le plus demandé avec le grand public et
avec les scolaires ont fait des ateliers
où il ya moyen de faire chercher des
gens on essaie de dire aux gens on fait
comme si vous étiez des mathématiciens
de mathématicienne sais pas si c'était
déjà fait et ouais voilà on leur donne
des problèmes et on leur fait se rendre
compte que eux aussi ont un cerveau et
que en fait les maths n'est pas séparée
réservée à une élite c'est juste un truc
voilà c'est comme beaucoup de choses
faut s'entraîner c'est mieux de
s'entraîner on peut avoir plus ou moins
de prédispositions mais tout le monde
peut trouver des choses en maths et donc
on essaie de faire chercher des gens de
faire en sorte que ça ressemble à la
recherche mathématique et donc on a mis
des motifs dessus on a discuté avec nos
collègues de bio pour avoir des motifs
qui peuvent évoquer aussi bien les maths
que la bio et voilà c'est c'est chouette
et puis sinon l'autre partie de notre
offre s'est essentiellement des exposés
et on a enfin réalisé un rêve qu'on a
depuis très longtemps qui est de
commencer à faire un cabinet de
curiosités mathématiques bien même des
étages des objets tellement partout que
l'on n'avait plus assez de place dans
les étagères donc on en a mis là on a
neuf on en a mis un peu partout un peu
partout un peu partout et l'idée c'est
de dire que on aime bien donner une idée
une image des mathématiques un peu plus
large que que ce qui est généralement
connu parler parler j'en ai donc là
l'idée voilà c'est que les gens peuvent
voir ça et se dire bon ok si je vois un
cercle je peux avoir une idée que ça
avec les maths
si je vois une machine étrange à 13,6 je
vois une pomme de pain je peux peut-être
plus me poser de question du lien avec
les maths et donc l'idée c'est que ça
peut susciter les questions et qu'on
commence à parler de plein de choses
donc je voulais juste montrer n'a parlé
de récup avec baptiste ça cet objet là
qui est là c'était un meuble en fait
dans le palais des découvertes on avait
commandé à nomeny zier
on avait un atelier de menuiserie
l'avait commandé juste un meuble un cube
quoi pour poser un truc dessus et puis
bah comme ils sont et qu'ils veulent
faire bien les choses nous ont fait je
vais pas creuser il va expliquer
pourquoi c'en est un mais en hypercube
ça s'appelle un hypercube donc quand on
a déménagé plutôt que de jeter
était suspendu ici on va pouvoir aussi
en parler en médiation alors ouais ouais
ouais c'est vraiment joli et il ya plein
de choses intéressantes à raconter
dessus et puis ça fait super dans le
décor comme voilà et comme tout le reste
je trouve mais je suis un petit peu de
parti pris est alors voilà ce que je
voudrais vous montrez du coup je me suis
dit que j'allais parler de ça au début
on a on a fait style je vais te demander
de quoi tu vas entendre par louvain
entendre parler tu choisis mais on n'a
pas le temps ou donc ces deux là
auraient envie d'entendre parler ça a
été réalisée dans l'atelier de
plasturgie cette fois dû du palais et
alors ça c'est passé complètement de
saison ça va commencer de plus en plus
de saison c'est pour parler de sondage
la question est on va pas faire de
politique
on reste dans la bonne humeur tout ça la
question est une question assez neutre
combien il ya de billy verte en
proportion à peu près là dedans tu as
une idée dispense à 10%
j'ai pas s'il va tout tout tout le monde
a droit de participer 1 10%
est-ce que c'est 10 % est ce que ces
cinq est ce que c'est vrai ce que tu dis
10 10 10 pour tous voilà et donc bah
comment on fait pour savoir lors il ya
une ya une solution qui serait de les
compter une par une
mais déjà ils sont dans le bocal dont
s'est complétée et en plus il y en a
beaucoup
donc ça va être long donc ce qu'on fait
c'est ce qu'on fait on fait un sondage
comme comme pour savoir pour qui les
gens vont voter tout ça l'ebit en gros
avantage elle ne demande pas ne change
pas de couleurs tout ça est donc là on y
va on mélange attention les oreilles on
mélange c'est très important parce que
si les divers tons plus lourde plus
légères évidemment voilà donc on mélange
est mal mais hélas on peut compter on a
en fait 25 petits emplacements là dedans
donc sur les 25 1 2 3 4 5 6 on a six qui
sont verts donc si vie verte sur 25 ans
multiplie par 4 ça doit donner à peu
près sur 100 wes il faut quatre 24 donc
ça veut dire que à peu près 24 % parce
que j'avais battu le voilà tu le vis pas
trop comme un échec ça va mais on peut
recommencer
oui on recommence
on recommence un beau mélange nos
collègues adorait quand on faisait ça
juste à côté de leur stade explose et
chimie on recommence
et là à y en a plus que deux donc tu
t'es encore trompé mais dans l'autre
sens cette fois puisque deux fois 4 ça
fait 8 8%
donc on est passé de 24 % à 8 % que je
pense qu'il ya un homme politique qui a
tenu un discours très convaincant pour
changer de couleur ouais il y aura plein
qu'on dit ok je suis plus verte que
blanche ou alors juste en fait c'est
normal que ça change à chaque fois c'est
un peu le principe du sondage est donc
ça ça permette d'expliquer d'où viennent
les fourchettes
quand on donne le résultat d'un sondage
on n'aurait jamais donné juste une
valeur ça n'a pas de sens on donne une
fourchette
on dit qu'il ya des votre approximations
voilà et c'est de ça que ça vient c'est
la variabilité ont fait la même
expérience mais évidemment ça change et
du hasard
voilà l'une des nombreuses choses qu'on
peut raconter il ya beaucoup d'autres
choses raconté mais il est l'heure de
passer en astronomie incroyable merci
beaucoup mais j'espère que tu feras un
feat avec le présentateur de motus ce
n'est pas sur un partenariat allait
parfait merci beaucoup pour enchaîner à
je vous propose une petite vidéo
impromptue une vidéo pour expliquer un
dispositif qui s'appelle un chercheur
une manip
bonjour je suis bénédicte leclerc et
responsables de l'uimm était un
chercheur une manip au palais de la
découverte
bienvenue à au palais de la découverte
et à un chercheur une manie un chercheur
une manif ça consiste à inviter des
chercheurs à présenter leurs travaux à
partir d'expériences qu'il réalise en
laboratoire ou d'expérience adapté il
présente au public de manière concrète
alors il ya un espace dédié à un
chercheur une manip que l'on présente un
petit peu pour rappeler un laboratoire
et il ya surtout une paillasse et une
manip dessus qui va être manipulé par le
chercheur alors les musées de sciences
aînés centre de culture scientifique en
gros deux manières de présenter la
science soit des exposés par les
médiateurs soit des conférences données
par des scientifiques mais qui n'ont pas
de manip l'originalité des chercheurs
une manip c'est de rassembler les deux
on a une manip qui a été montée et s'est
présentée par des chercheurs directement
l'idée
date de 1937 de la fondation du palais
de la découverte puisque l'idée de jean
perrin qui et prix nobel de physique
c'était de faire revenir la science au
pied du public de faire que le public
puisse rencontrer directement la science
et puissent découvrir la science
alors qu'est ce qui va changer dans le
dans les étincelles sur un chercheur
manip presque rien puisque le principe
reste le même
les chercheurs viendront présenter des
manips au public en avant première les
thèmes d'un chercheur une manip la
biopile vous allez apprendre comment
dépolluer l'eau et produire un faible
courant électrique avec des champignons
le fonctionnement des cellules
éventuellement jusqu'à l'apparition des
cancers et le troisième vous allez
apprendre à fabriquer une comète
alors la première la toute première aux
étincelles
un chercheur une manip aux étincelles
c'est le 19 juin
retenez cette date nous voici au présent
à présent au pacte orium et pour cela
nous retrouvons jean veut donc du coup
que du vieux banon est non désolé là là
pour le coup cette fois ci il ya
essentiellement du neuf pour des raisons
sécurité essentiellement on a acheté des
fauteuils un terme que vous allez
découvrir avec avec philippe il ya une
petite anecdote sur le pupitre qui sert
au médiateur qui a été réalisé à partir
de des placards du bureau du président
d'universcience donc je laisserai le
découvrir et je voulais juste rajouter
un dernier petit mot sur sur les 13
entreprises qui ont réalisé tous ces
aménagements
ce sont des entreprises locales
d'ile-de-france qui sont qui sont
engagés dans l'économie sociale et
solidaire et dans l'économie circulaire
et voilà je voulais juste les remercier
parce qu'ils ont fait un super travail
effectivement on peut le voir là c'est
pas dégueu très bien merci
christopher maintenant nous
en compagnie de philippe qui est donc
médias t'as le bonjour à tous
alors le plénum on est une activité un
petit peu particulière parce que nous on
a besoin d'une salle spécialement dédié
une salle qui a forcément la forme d'une
coupole comme vous pouvez le voir ici
motivé et je vous repose bas sans plus
tarder de me suivre à l'intérieur en
route
ouvrir un petit peu plus tard dans au
cours du procès au cours de l'été je
pense quand on sera sûr de pouvoir
vraiment faire les séances dans des
conditions absolument optimum mais ça
n'empêche pas que d'ores et déjà parlé
rapidement de ce qu'on va vous proposer
quand on va se retrouver au cours de
l'été alors je vais commencer un autre
appareil c'est un design alors c'est
vraiment la marque de référence depuis
près d'un siècle sur les fabricants de
planétarium
vous avez ici un projecteur vidéo
numérique qui va projeter le ciel étoilé
à 360° sur cette coupole qui ferme après
huit mètres de diamètre ce projecteur il
était depuis ce pupitre de contrôle et
c'est ici d'ailleurs que vous allez
retrouver sur le pourtour du public
ces fameuses étagères du bureau de notre
cher président alors ce qui fait notre
spécificité à new hope la hauteur du
palais de la découverte c'est qu'on a
toujours fait on continue à le faire
d'espérance en direct intégral c'est à
dire que c'est le médiateur scientifique
qui à la fois pilote l'appareil en
direct depuis le pupitre mais aussi il
fait les commentaires en direct
parce que bon on considère que y'a rien
qui remplace cette interaction ce
contact direct qu'on peut avoir le
public
alors qu'on retrouve et on va vous
proposer aux trois types de séance trois
thèmes de séance le premier thème ça
s'appelle balade céleste su en gros une
initiation à l'astronomie pour le jeune
public
le deuxième thème eh bien il s'appelle
m solaire qui parle de lui-même et le
troisième on change d'échelle ça
s'appelle et toi toutes nos séances au
cna est un homme ça commence toujours
par vous montrer le ciel tel qu'on peut
le voir alors c'est un ciel idéal sans
aucune pollution lumineuse mais tel
qu'on peut le voir depuis paris on vous
montre les étoiles qui sont les plus
brillantes convoi dans le ciel les
planètes qui sont ville en ce moment qui
des objets peut-être un peu plus
difficile d'avoir des âmes à des toiles
des galaxies qu'on peut voir à l'oeil nu
aussi ça c'est pas facile
et ensuite ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on
va garder un moment cette perspective du
ciel vu depuis le sol parce qu'on trouve
que c'est vraiment important d'avoir ça
et il est temps d'accélérer pour
identifier ensemble
les principaux mouvements apparent qui
semble animer le ciel alors par exemple
le mouvement de la terre sur elle même
qui fait qu' on a l'impression que tout
le ciel tourne autour d'eux est en ouest
en 24 heures le mouvement de la terre
autour du soleil est responsable du
cycle des saisons et puis les mouvements
un petit peu compliqué et alambiqué des
eaux planète est ce qui veut dire
vagabond en grec et ensuite en deuxième
partie de séance et bien là on vous
propose un voyage on va quitter le sol
de la terre et l'eau voyage qu'on fait
ça il va déprendre lui un petit peu du
thème de la séance
alors on peut aller par exemple pour
commenter faire quand les astronautes
d'apollo aller jusqu'à là lui on peut
aller derrière la lune voir la face
cachée de la vie qu'on voit pas depuis
le sol ensuite on peut se balader dans
le système solaire
allez sur la planète mars qu'on peut
même se poser sur la planète mars
plus loin dans le système solaire pas sa
grande star c'est la planète saturne
avec ses anneaux et avec notre vaisseau
spatial virtuel
on peut même plongé au coeur des anneaux
de saturne c'est vraiment assez
impressionnante
et puis ensuite suivant le thème qu'on
aborde là encore changer d'échelle en
cévennes encore plus aux visites les
étoiles de l'environnement du soleil et
puis on s'éloigne dans la galaxie
jusqu'à un moment donné pouvoir même
sortir de la galaxie et la regarder de
l'extérieur
et puis ça s'arrête pas là on peut
continuer s'éloigner encore plus voir
notre galaxie parmi d'autres galaxies
dans notre âme à local reculer encore
ferme à zoom arrière gigantesque voir
comment se structure l'univers à très
grande échelle et on peut aller jusqu'au
bout du bout du bout
jusqu'en limite absolue de ce qu'on peut
voir ce qu'on appelle le fond diffus
cosmologique rayonnement fossile qui
nous date des premiers instants du big
bang et qu'on peut observer comme un
faible steve le rayonnement au monde
arabe alors voilà c'est vraiment rapide
c'est ça qu'on pourra vous montrer dès
qu'on pourra vous accueillir à nouveau
on vous attend avec impatience j'espère
tu veux donner envie de venir nous
apprennent tout à fait je j'ai très hâte
que ça vous et là on vous accueille avec
plaisir super merci beaucoup merci vous
propose de sortir du pétard y sommes
pour l conclusions a tout de suite et
bien merci beaucoup aux chefs des
internautes merci aussi aux équipes de
cette enseigne du palais de la
découverte au médiateur qui font
travailler fort 1000e forme il est
absolument faux remis le et d'ailleurs
c'est un petit peu aussi surtout pour
eux qu'on vient ici pour les sciences
mais aussi pour les découvrir ce que
c'est des gens absolument merveilleux je
ne sais plus parler donc voilà j'espère
que cette visite vous aura donné envie
de visiter ce nouveau lieu de science
qui est situé donc dans le 15ème
arrondissement de paris à côté du parc
andré citroën
n'oubliez pas de réserver en ligne sur
le site internet du palais de la
découverte palais trait d'union
découverte point fr réservation
obligatoire
ne loupez pas ça donc dès aujourd'hui
vous pouvez réserver une place parce que
aujourd'hui c'est l'ouverture
voilà donc j'espère que ça vous a plu et
si jamais vous avez raté la visite ou si
vous voulez la revoir vous pouvez aller
sur youtube
probablement pour voir le replay de
cette émission
à bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]